this is the danger if a group like
al-qaeda has a haven in afghanistan to
plot
acts of international terror
the september the 11th attacks on the
united states
prompted the us-led invasion to combat
the threat
but 20 years on as american and british
forces draw down
a former spy chief has warned al qaeda
could rise again
if we're not there it seems to be their
capacity to organise in afghanistan
is going to go up and we know from
history
the risks of that and what might happen
sir alex younger recalled what the uk
and its allies found when they first
entered afghanistan to hunt al qaeda and
oust the taliban regime that
accommodated them
what we saw there was a was a level of
terrorist
infrastructure that could only have been
imagined before we got there um
training camps that would have been not
out of place you know sort of
conventional
military or special forces barracks
he therefore cautioned against
neglecting afghanistan
as happened when a previous russian
intervention
ended in 1989 it would be an enormous
mistake
for us to to do that again the reality
is that there are groups there
we've been very successful in disrupting
both daesh and al qaeda
they're on the back foot but they will
be wrong
patently declaring that they have gone
away
and they have the capacity to regenerate
these militants
linked to islamic state or daesh
surrendered to afghan forces in 2018
but around 2000 remain at large
while al qaeda once significantly
diminished
has up to 500 fighters in the country
so we are going to have to think very
carefully in the absence of of troops on
the ground about how we
deal with that it's vital that we don't
make the mistakes that we made last time
around
what would be the consequences if the
west did turn their back again
well i think if um if terrorist groups
are allowed to regenerate
somewhere like afghanistan it will be it
will lead to more threat
on the shores of our country and our
allies
on the ground some locals are mobilizing
to support the afghan government against
the taliban
the former mi6 boss predicted three
scenarios for the country some kind of
compromise
a full taliban takeover or most likely
civil war we cannot hide the fact that a
more chaotic afghanistan is going to be
more dangerous for the international
community writ large and that includes
us
it's a prospect that's painful to
contemplate for soldiers
like andy left with mental and physical
scars from their afghan
service one comfort was the belief
they'd helped to keep the streets of the
uk
safer now even that's in doubt
no words can describe
how angry i am about it knowing that
the men we've lost over the men and
women we've lost over there
and it just feels like we're going
backwards
at this point it just the entire thing
just felt like a waste of time
not completely the taliban now know
they'll suffer
if afghanistan again becomes a launch
pad for terrorism
the uk and its allies will also hope a
network
they've built to counter the threat can
cope
debra haynes sky news